Transcriptor: Elena Rodríguez Linares
Revisor: Paula Motter
¿Hay futuro?
¿Tenemos futuro?
¿Queremos futuro?
Parece una pregunta obvia.
Es un determinante biológico.
Y, sin embargo,
por cómo reaccionamos,
por cómo hacemos las cosas,
no estoy tan seguro de que esto sea así.
Si les preguntan
a los ambientalistas apocalípticos,
el futuro es bastante oscuro:
el cambio climático,
la invasión de especies exóticas,
la contaminación,
el sobreuso.
Diríamos que, desde esa perspectiva,
el futuro, al menos, no es muy extenso.
Si les preguntan
a los desarrollistas a ultranza,
el futuro no solamente es maravilloso,
sino que es muy halagüeño.
Desde esta perspectiva,
la tecnología,
el crecimiento económico permanente,
la equidad,
van a generar una sociedad de bienestar.
Y ninguno de los dos está mintiendo.
Cada uno de ellos tiene sus elementos
para suponer qué es posible.
Para la ciencia,
ni el optimismo ni el pesimismo
son opciones.
La ciencia tiene que partir
de la generación de datos
hacia la información,
hacia el conocimiento
y, más recientemente,
hacia la interfaz política,
hacia mostrar todo ese conocimiento
para la toma de decisiones.
También depende de a quién
se le haga la pregunta.
Si es al planeta,
y permanentemente lo discutimos
en nuestras conversaciones,
el planeta tiene al menos
el doble de tiempo que ha estado
dándole vueltas al sol.
El planeta requiere la energía solar
y la ha tenido permanentemente
los últimos 4500
o 5000 millones de años.
Y el sol tiene
la reserva de fisión nucelar
de hidrógeno y de helio suficiente
para otros 5000 millones de años más.
El planeta parece
no tener mayores inconvenientes.
No es una pregunta que le importe.
Y, adicionalmente,
hacia 1970, en esa década,
James Lovelock, un autor norteamericano,
planteó la teoría Gaia.
En la teoría Gaia,
el planteamiento es que el planeta
es una especie de ser consciente
que logra regular sus ciclos:
su ciclo de carbono, su ciclo de agua,
su ciclo de nitrógeno,
su ciclo de fosfato.
De manera que
no tiene mayor inconveniente.
Y, de hecho, nosotros somos un mal menor,
una especie de fiebre que
ni siquiera genera mayor preocupación.
Ahora, si la pregunta
está vinculada a la especie:
"¿Qué tanto futuro tiene la especie?",
la preocupación tampoco es mayor.
Esta es una especie relativamente nueva.
Los mamíferos tienen de promedio
entre uno y dos millones
de años de duración
antes de convertirse en otra especie.
Y nosotros apenas tenemos
entre 750 000 y 400 000 años.
O sea que, en el peor de los casos,
la especie podría tener incluso
el doble del tiempo del que ha estado
en el planeta.
Sin embargo, cuando lo que
nos preguntamos es si la civilización,
si la humanidad,
si como nos reconocemos como sociedad,
tiene futuro,
hay unos umbrales de incertidumbre
realmente grandes.
Y ahí es donde conviene poner
el dedo sobre la llaga.
Estamos agotando los recursos del planeta.
La WWF viene planteando, por ejemplo,
que el 89 % de las poblaciones silvestres
de la fauna y la flora
de Centro y Suramérica
ha desaparecido.
Los dos grados de cambio climático
que solicitó el Panel del Cambio Climático
en París hace unos años
son tímidamente respondidos
por los gobiernos.
Desde esas perspectivas,
realmente tenemos dificultades
para suponer esa resiliencia.
Sin embargo, la situación
de Colombia no es la peor.
Colombia, a diferencia
de lo anteriormente mencionado,
es un país que tiene
la proporción de áreas naturales
y áreas transformadas
contraria al resto del planeta.
Si el planeta tiene
una tercera parte natural
y dos terceras partes transformadas,
sucede lo contrario en Colombia:
tenemos dos terceras partes naturales
y una tercera parte transformada.
En apenas el 1 %
de la tierra que hay en el planeta,
del territorio continental del planeta,
se alberga el 10 %
de las poblaciones del planeta.
Eso quiere decir que tenemos
diez veces más que el promedio,
e incluso que tenemos 100 veces más
que el que menos tiene.
Once países tienen el 70 %
del agua dulce del planeta.
Colombia es uno de ellos.
Colombia es el primer territorio
donde hay más aves y orquídeas.
Es el segundo en anfibios,
mariposas y peces de agua dulce.
Es el tercero en plantas y reptiles.
Es el cuarto en mamíferos.
Y no es el país más grande.
Es un país de apenas
un millón de kilómetros cuadrados.
De tamaño intermedio.
Y buena parte de los otros países
que tienen un 'ranking' mejor
son países considerablemente más grandes.
Sin embargo, no todo es tranquilidad.
Nuestro país tiene inmensos problemas
alrededor de la sostenibilidad.
La resiliencia parece ser
un soporte grande para la sociedad
y, sin embargo,
hay muchas cosas por hacer.
Por mencionar algunas:
el Convenio sobre la Diversidad Biológica,
que es el organismo rector de los países
para los temas de
conservación del medio ambiente,
propuso una meta
hace unos cuatro o cinco años
de que debíamos tener el 17 %
del territorio terrestre conservado
y el 10 % del marino.
El país cumplió lo marino con excelencia.
El país está cumpliendo lo terrestre
muy próximamente.
Los países de la región han logrado
también tener unas metas de conservación
por encima de las que planteó
el Convenio de Diversidad Biológica.
Y, sin embargo,
seguimos perdiendo biodiversidad.
En ese contexto,
¿qué estamos haciendo mal?
¿Es el mecanismo por el cual estamos
haciendo conservación de biodiversidad?
¿O es por el paradigma con el cual
estamos haciendo gestión de biodiversidad?
En los 70, cuando estaba trabajando
con áreas protegidas del INDERENA,
el contexto era
"la tragedia de los comunes",
que propuso el biólogo Hardin en el 1976.
En 2008 Elinor Ostrom
gana el Premio Nobel de Economía
hablando del medio ambiente
y proponiendo un paradigma diferente,
que es la gobernanza comunitaria
de recursos naturales.
Ese tránsito paradigmático
nos lo tenemos que creer.
Tenemos que convertirlo
en elemento de gestión.
De hecho, habría que plantear
que el mismo concepto de la preservación
puede ser incluso antinatural.
La preservación supone
dejar algo estático.
Y lo único estático en la biodiversidad
es la dinámica.
De manera que la preservación
dejaría muchas dudas
alrededor de que sea un buen referente
para la conservación de la biodiversidad.
Al menos hay que suponer que no podemos
seguir haciendo más de lo mismo.
Tenemos que innovar.
Tenemos que ser consecuentes
con esos tránsitos de paradigma
e invertir cada vez
en mejores herramientas
para la gestión de la biodiversidad.
La balanza económica del país
se basa en elementos de extracción,
de recursos que se extraen del territorio:
el carbón, el petróleo, el oro.
Y Colombia, en ningún caso,
es ninguno de los primeros 10.
En petróleo somos el 21,
en carbón somos el 11.
En oro, ni siquiera alcanzamos a estar
dentro de los primeros 20.
Mientras que la inversión
en temas de biotecnología,
biomímesis, elementos "bio",
está bastante limitada.
De manera que tendríamos
que hacer una enorme gestión
alrededor de investigación,
ciencia y conocimiento
hacia patentes y hacia la posibilidad
de que haya elementos de la economía
hacia donde el planeta se está moviendo.
Nada diferente de eso.
Una de las aproximaciones
que mejor se está desarrollando
es la de la transición socioecológica
hacia la sostenibilidad.
Este concepto pretende entrar
en la gestión ambiental del Antropoceno.
No seguir pensando
en gestión ambiental del Pleistoceno,
de hace mucho tiempo,
de volver a recuperar
territorios naturales.
Todo cambia.
Pero cambia con posibilidades
de que siga siendo funcional.
Estocolmo, en 1972, en la primera
Cumbre de la Tierra,
planteó el desarrollo sostenible
como el gran eslogan.
La Cumbre de Río de Janeiro en 1992
planteó actuar local y pensar global.
Siguen siendo válidas.
Tenemos que seguir pensando
en esa localidad, en actuar.
Y buena parte de ustedes
y el ambientalismo
son muy fuertes en Colombia
sobre ese actuar local.
Sin embargo, pensar global es necesario.
Pero incluso al margen
de lo que esperemos de los gobiernos
o de lo que hagamos como Estado,
la responsabilidad
de la conservación de la biodiversidad
y de la gestión ambiental
es de todos y cada uno de ustedes.
Cualquiera de las decisiones diarias
que toman sobre el plástico,
el mercado con bolsas,
la movilidad sostenible,
dependen exclusivamente de ustedes.
No podemos seguirles
exigiendo a los gobiernos
que hagan lo que nosotros
tenemos que empezar a hacer.
Y luego, claro, presionar a los gobiernos
para que se cumplan esos elementos.
Pongo un tema corto, rápido.
Me movilizo en bicicleta
al menos durante este siglo.
Eso es lo que hago.
Pero ya ni siquiera por consciencia
ambiental ni compromiso social.
Es que la generación de endorfinas
que produce la movilidad
en bicicleta en Bogotá
genera los niveles de adicción
a los que ya estoy sometido.
Les invito a reflexionar
y a tomar decisiones conscientes.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)